90 seconds okay okay i'm gonna lose
what's up i'm molly waynes and this is
90 second trivia with the academy what
do i win
okay i'm ready i'm ready what movie does
robert de niro's famous line you talking
to me come from you talking to me a few
comments
taxi drug taxis driver rydell high
school is the setting for which
influential 70s musical movie greece it
would be greece
greece is the word
yeah come on more theater
julie andrews won the best actress oscar
for which 1964 musical 64.
the one she was on top of the mountain
what do you call it sound of music
sound of music
[Music]
right what song did aretha's thing in
the 1980 film the blues brothers
think oh thank you jodie foster played
fbi agent clarice starling in what 1991
film silence of the lambs that would be
silence of the land
silence
okay what was the first feature animated
movie released in history fantasia
mickey mouse something uh
it's a disney one snow white in the
summer drawers and snow white
uh yeah
which 90s movie has the best selling
soundtrack of all time oh come on
i don't know
bodyguard
what is your favorite aretha franklin
song 10 seconds ain't no way doctor feel
good
you're supposed to say respect that's
our joke respect
my song is respect r-e-s-b-e-c-t
yes boom there it is
you